diehard Gossip Girl fans are pretty
bummed about this news the reboot on HBO
max has officially been delayed until
2021 since production hasn't even
started yet here's the silver lining
that gives you plenty of time to fall
back in love with the original pay every
Snyder's Gossip Girl here
this show does take place in a bit of a
heightened reality everything's a little
more sparkly
there's the blonde ed girl the queen bee
the bad boy could pretty boy the lonely
boy and the mysterious blogger voiced by
Kristen Bell who spells all their dirty
secrets
[Applause]
we are scandalous show you know in the
in the best way possible drinking drugs
and hookups there's no shortage of
scandal for these privileged private
school kids and Gossip Girl is always
watching
why so thirsty ass they're born and bred
with the silver spoon in their mouth
Lake was about to quit acting and enroll
in college when she landed the role of
Serena Leighton also auditioned for the
part but producers felt she was a better
fit for Blair for than 20 year old one
of the roles so badly she dyed her
blonde hair brunette to try and convince
them most popular most want to be
popular most likely to hook up with
anybody
oh come eat II was on set for the first
season in 2007 Gossip Girl was actually
filmed in New York and as a gained
popularity fans would follow production
around the city and even when they took
the show to Paris part of the obsession
the fashion these teens were wearing
labels like Chanel Marc Jacobs and Vera
Wang
we shopped a lot and we are stuck with
school uniforms but you can always dress
it up with a $1,500 gold
horned owl pen right fancy suede knee
high boots thigh high boots you know
high season two designers were lining up
to have their clothes worn by Blake
enlightens I own half of Serena's
wardrobe so they think that our style is
fairly similar sometimes like shared
another similarity with her character
Serena's sooner or later people are
gonna figure out we're dating she and
Penn Badgley were also a couple off
screen dating for three years
and what about those rumors that our
reps on set between Blake and Layton
Blair and Serena have a lot of frenemies
action an executive producer says the
leading ladies were friendly but they
were not friends like Serena and Blair
so where is the cast now Blake and
Layton her mom's pins about to be a dad
at West wicks got abs and chase Crawford
is starring in a superhero series as for
the reboots well the only original cast
member returning is Kristen Bell as the
voice of Gossip Girl that's the Cadi
version of me the truth always comes out
I'm really excited xoxo Gossip Girl
[Music]